[Music]  hello there fortnite's Winterfest is  here yet again 14 free gifts to open one  per day as those gifts are not random at  all I'll open them all from left to  right to help you plan out your opening  order do me a favor click like if this  was useful and maybe leave a comment too  here's everything in those boxes in  fortnite Winterfest 2022.  [Music]  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  there are two boxes we cannot open just  yet this one we have to save until last  which is this skin and Guff is holding  on tight to the last present which will  become this hopefully this video was  helpful I'm Adam you're awesome see you  next time